Speaker 1: Hey, this is kind of interesting.
Here's another of these very few examples where
the former president Donald Trump seems to concede
that he did lose the 2020 election, although he
kind of does it with a caveat. There's a very
interesting interview in The Atlantic, and it's
written about in The Guardian, and we're going to
link to both. There's The Atlantic article What I
Learned When Trump Tried to Correct The Record by
Julian Zelizer. This is from a couple of days ago,
and then there was also an interesting article in
The Guardian as well. I didn't win the election.
Trump admits defeat in session with historians.
Trump also said Iran, China and South Korea
were happy Biden won, adding that the election
was rigged and lost. Donald Trump has admitted
he did not win the 2020 election. I didn't win the
election, he said. The admission came in a video
interview with a panel of historians convened by
Julian Zelizer, a Princeton professor and editor
of the presidency of Donald Trump. The interview
was published earlier this week by The Atlantic,
describing his attempts to make South Korea pay
more for U.S. military assistance. Trump said
Moon Jae in, the South Korean president was among
the happiest world leaders after the 2020 election
put Joe Biden in the White House by not winning
the election. Trump said he was the happiest man,
I would say in order China was no. Iran was the
happiest. Trump also said the election was rigged
and lost. Trump's refusal to accept defeat by
Biden provoked attempts to overturn results in
key states, as we know. Trump was impeached a
second time. Trump remains free to run for the
White House again in 2024, which he has repeatedly
hinted he would do. Writing for The Atlantic.
Zelizer said Trump was the one who had decided to
reach out to a group of professional historians
so that we produce an accurate book, an accurate
book. Trump seemed to want the approval of
historians without any understanding of how
historians gather evidence or render judgment.
So it's always with a caveat. It's always with
a caveat. And at this point, we understand
there is this double standard, right? If you
one, how could you run again? But I guess it's
you can't serve more than two terms. So
even though he won 2020, he can run again.
But he didn't win because it was rigged, and so
he lost, but he should have won it. It's this
endless loop of logic. What I think is really
interesting about this is that Trump is more
regularly now saying things like it was lost,
it was rigged. But we did lose to some degree.
And for a lot of people on the right who
are committed to this as an ideology,
they're not committed to it as a fact. We've said
before that for some Trumpists, they literally
believe Trump won and we've seen in interviews
with them at Trump rallies, they they seem
genuine when they say Trump really won, it was
stolen. Trump actually won. He got more votes in
more states. He had more electoral votes. He won
four other Trumpists. It's what you say to show
that you're on the right team, that you're still
on the team. And they may not literally believe
that Donald Trump got more votes should have
been president and the election was stolen.
But you say it to signal an allegiance to
Donald Trump, and I've spoken before about how,
for many of these folks, they see themselves as
being in a war and they see it sort of like a holy
war. And when you're at war, you sort of say or do
what you have to do. And even if it's not honest
because of it being a means to an end and that
listen, even if we take some casualties, it's OK
because it's a necessary war or whatever the case
may be. In some sense, that is what this statement
Trump won has become for many of them. And even
though Trump has increasingly said, OK, well, I
lost, but it was rigged or whatever. Remember when
we didn't find weapons of mass destruction in Iraq
despite George W. Bush and the late Colin
Powell and others telling us they're there?
They weren't there. We didn't find them.
And even after that was an undeniable fact.
Many Bush supporters kept saying, We did find
them. Some of them probably thought that we
did. Much like now, some Trumpists probably
believe Trump did win. But on the other hand,
for some of them, it was just something that you
say. And this is something that it's a phenomena
that exists in politics that's bigger than Trump.
The particular lies right now are associated with
Trump, but it's no surprise people do this
for all you can call it cognitive dissonance.
You can call it magical thinking. There's a
lot of different things that you can call it,
but don't expect it to go away. Even if
Trump more consistently concedes that
he did lose, it wasn't fair. But he
did lose, as he recently did once again